Hello there, Ron. Hello there Richard.
Welcome back.
Hey, Danny.
How's it going?
It's a real bang up day.
Banged up day.
bang up
Bang up now. I've never heard of the expression. Is that does that imply
something positive or not positive?
Right now it implies lots of fireworks.
Oh, oh, there's
our national holiday Fourth of
July right right by wow. Yeah.
I'm not been keeping data. I'm not I've kind of lost track
of the dates. But happy Fourth of July.
you
and
others who are of course celebrating and they're
just joining in.
Okay, let me do that.
Share my screen.
Let's make this a banged up session.
Okay.
And hello, everybody else. Welcome. Welcome back to
I'll come back to the session.
Let me go ahead and share my screen.
share screen
There we go.
and apply
Before I begin, let me just make a
comment about slag.
And this is especially for you.
Laura because I saw this in your email.
for
Slack you don't actually need to download the
application.
The one I use is the web version and
the link to the web version is here on
the side sidebar.
So when you visit the dashboard click on the link.
NOW Watch What Happens
You will see something that looks you might see something like that. Looks
like this now I use Firefox. You might be
using chrome doesn't matter. You'll be prompted to open the
application.
the desktop application
All you have to do is click on cancel.
and then you can use
you just click on the link to direct you to
the web browser.
and of course raw newer allowing to this video, you know, and if
a few sessions ago that that you
know, it forces you to open this
The desktop version. Unfortunately, I couldn't find something that that
you know the best I couldn't find an alternative that
is as good as slack this code.
The power Discord is we have a huge, you know.
number of people in here it will be
I'm impossible to get it to join Discord because
not many it's not as why they adopted as this court many people use stack
professionally.
So it's it's no bother for them to
You slack, so please keep that at mind. Okay, if you
don't join slack or
if you don't participate on slack you're going to miss out.
On discussions attachments exercises
and you won't be able to ask.
I mean, it's the best place you want to go if you have any questions.
So just keep that in mind. Yeah, I click on the sidebar.
This link here in the sidebar.
And if you prompt it to open the applications click on
cancel and navigate your way to the link.
Very well. Let's talk about today's agenda.
Now we are.
starting module 3 module 3 and
module 4
are two weeks in duration, and they are continuous.
why well because
we're going to be focusing on Matrix operations.
the different types of matrices
Matrix operations the applications of Matrix operations,
and of course
Matrix operations with numpy
today for example
We're going to talk cover a few important things.
gaussian elimination
I've talked about this.
And I've shown you a picture
that should give you an idea, but I actually want us to do it.
an actual exercise
we look at the notation.
For gaussian elimination and we will apply the numpy and
the reason I want us to start with gaussian elimination
because this will give us a reason to want
to talk about different types of matrices.
And one particular type of Matrix that we want to look at
is the identity Matrix.
the identity Matrix and the inverse Matrix
and in order for us to understand this we would have to
Talk about Matrix arithmetic multiplication in
particular.
So for number one, we will do this for linear algebra,
and then of course.
numpy
Okay, and then we can move on and talk about
Led composition. So I
Should you one algorithm?
That was for one part of the LED composition. So
we want to revisit that today LED composition.
And actual example of it.
both in linear algebra and numpy
now numpy has a method for
LED composition so first we will see how
we can do manually with numpy and then
we'll use the method.
LED composition, of course
is one
powerful technique for solving systems of
equations. So gaussian elimination is one of them this is
but
Cumbersome, right? I said this before it is you have to do
a lot of arithmetic row interchanging to get to a solution.
But this is another one.
Okay, so by putting our focus on LED composition
will learn.
the purpose
of different shapes different Arrangements
of matrices numpy
and of course
Later on, we can apply we can transfer
our skills to talking about determinants than
the characteristic polynomial and leading up
to PCA. And then once we're
at PC, then we ready for module 4 we will
talk about neural networks.
And dimensional reduction. Okay,
so we have two weeks to
really properly understand matrices
Okay.
All right.
and I I think we probably
going to have to revisit this again
and
on Tuesday Wednesday, excuse me, our second session because
we do have to do a lot of quite a bit of writing to
really understand what's going on in here. Okay, let's begin.
I will open a new file.
And I will call this.
Matrix
operations
Okay, and this is for yeah, this is for later.
Okay.
Matrix operations
so
let me give you some context.
By revisiting the systems of equity
the system of equations we had from our last.
session
the linear programming problem remember the
objective function and the
Oh and the constraints?
So I'm just going to copy those constraints.
And this is what we had before.
And also I edited the video.
From our last Edition because I was living out.
The scientific notation part I'm just going to keep it in here,
right? So this is not
This is not 3,000. It's actually 30 million and This is 40 million.
Okay. Now if we the way we
found the roots of these.
Constraints was through classical algebra
right move this term to the right side move
that term to this side.
And then you know what algebra is about it's about limit. It's
about simplifying it right cancellation canceling from
both sides adding from adding to both sides reducing from
both sides dividing Etc.
gaussian elimination
allows us to solve for the roots, but
Without having to move the terms from one
side to the next.
and it is the stepping stone to get into LED composition which
I don't want to say simplifies, but
Makes the process more efficient.
So what we're going to look at is solving systems of equations.
more efficiently
anyway to represent this.
these two inequalities
and of course what we did in
the lp problem was to express these as equations.
but
it would get this.
Matrix
so obviously we would not bring the variables in
here. We would know what variables these numbers
stand for because if we follow the order right 100x,
so that's 100 is
of social with x.
This 100 is associated with that why you get the idea?
And the reason I put these parentheses is so that you know
that you know, I didn't really for this for this term.
So you know that this is one number.
This is one number.
Okay. Now this is called an augmented Matrix.
It's called augmented because
this Matrix is actually the union of
two.
The Matrix for what's on the
left side of the inequality inequalities and what's
on the right side of the inequalities
so
augmented matrices would also be
denoted like so
You would put a vertical bar.
I could put
some latex here to space them out a little bit.
You have a question Ron. I think you've raised your
hand.
Yeah, and I hope I'm not jumping ahead. But
is there some significance to the fact that
in your equation on the
right side, you're listing it as 3,000 times
10 to the fourth as opposed to.
3.0 times 10 to the seventh
Oh, yeah, there's some reason for that.
yes, the answer is it was easier
for me because I took this problem just change the
numbers a little bit from the problem the book and
yeah, it's it was not gonna matter to the content. No, no.
No. I just wanted to I was too lazy
with the algebra, you know, I don't like to do addition to
subtract. So I just
Pended in the problem. It was a had to do with wheat in barley.
And it was 3,000,4000 pounds.
So adopted this prop. Yeah, I I
turned this from a small company to an entire,
you know state-owned container manufacturer.
So 3,000 pounds is nothing for them. So I
had to
you know blow up the proportion. So I went with 30 million power
30 million pounds.
So it was laziness and that's it.
Okay.
Yes.
So let me show you how we would go about solving this.
system of inequalities with gaussian elimination
so here
and I'll come back to why I even brought up
augmented matrices because it has to with LED composition when
we do LED composition.
We separate.
the
terms on the left side of the equation and the terms
of the right side of the equation, okay?
So, let me let me get I'll come
back to this idea later.
Okay, I'll come back to this.
So this is
representing
inequalities
Or even equations for that matter. It doesn't really matter.
with you or
in a system of equally in a system
equations
assistant matrices
in a matrix
Okay.
so here
we have our solar systems. Now. How would we
solve this?
again to solve a system
is to have
an upper triangle
an upper triangle looks like this.
Upper triangular Matrix. Sorry
and an upper triangular Matrix
This is the upper trying right? This is the other triangle.
You have a leading zeros.
Under their main or what we call the principal diagonal.
So every number to the right or above the
principal diagonal is a non-zero value.
and everything obviously below that is a
This is zero.
So this is called Echelon 4 this whole
Matrix, but that is called the upper. This is the upper triangle.
now
to solve for the roots of the
inequalities
the numbers
of the upper triangle must also be once
so this would be one one one and you know,
everything else that we would be zero.
Okay, so for Led composition, we don't
need to make these ones.
But when we do gaussian elimination, we do
what these to be once. Anyway, what I'm trying to say is that this is upper triangle.
Okay, so we need to get our inequality our
system rather in Upper triangular form and then
get these.
What why do we do also called pivots the numbers across the
principal diagonal cultivates?
We need to make these pivots equal to one.
So let me show you and of course. This is a
this is reduced. Well reduce row Echelon
form. So once we get the pivots across the
diagonal equal to one we have then achieved reduced row
Echelon form.
I'm going to keep this picture as reference.
so
reduced
five
a row
echelon
for
let's make a little bit bigger.
Okay.
one one
so, let's see how we can do this equation.
So I'm going to copy it again.
And paste it.
with the Galaxy elimination
That's what we're going to talk about now.
gaussian elimination
we can use these Matrix we can use.
one row
to either
and we usually would eliminate okay to when you
get your Matrix in
reduced row Echelon form you have eliminated the
roads.
To eliminate means well again you have
leading ones on you have one on the principal
diagonal zeros.
below the principal diagonal
so in order for us to eliminate
these rows we can use them against each other.
So, for example, I can take row number two.
Subtract it from row number one or vice versa,
or I can multiply one of these rows by
some other number.
and then
that row
whose values have now become multiples of some other
number I can subtract from the first row.
This one should be difficult to do so for example and just again
for notational convenience.
I'm going to lose.
That tend to the power 4 and I hope you're okay with
that. I'm just gonna lose that because you know the separate the
notation.
the easier it will be for us to
keep track of what's going on.
and I'm gonna lose this parentheses really get
all that clutter out of the way.
So again, I want this to be a leading one.
And you know what just to simplify this
so we don't spend too much time. I'm going to reorder these and that's perfectly
fine. The that's within Gauss
and elimination. You can swap roles. Okay. Anyway, I
what I've done is I've now swapped.
other roles, in fact to denote this we
would do we would say this r
sub 2
and then a right arrow.
R sub 1
That means R2 has been replaced with R1.
now in your opinion
How can I
Get this to be reduced.
Assume this was two.
This was one and this was one and one.
What would we have to do to reduce this to eliminate
this role?
Well, I would say we would subtract row two
from Row 1.
so the difference of this
row and that row and then
the
Result of that difference. I would
put back into Row 1.
Let me show you what I mean. So what I'm going to do is I'm going to subtract row two
from Row 1.
and the order is important right because
If I subtract 200 minus 100, I'll get a
positive number. Whereas I'll get a negative number
the other that we round so I'm going to subtract row two from Row 1
and then I'm going to take this evaluation.
This result and replace it with the
Row 1 so I will get something that looks like this.
This becomes 100.
So 200 minus
100 gives you 100.
100 minus 100 this is going to give me zero.
And then 4,000 minus 3,000 that's gonna give me
1,000.
There we go. So I have 100 up
here.
Now I need to get this.
To be a zero.
Okay.
We're doing calcium elimination.
Now, let's see how I can get rid of that. I can subtract. Well,
well 100 minus 100 and so
basically this
I will subtract.
This Row from that row and then
the result.
I will plug it inside Row 1.
But if I subtract this from that, I'm going
to get a I'm going to get a negative 2000. I don't want negative two thousand.
So I'll do Row one minus row two, so I'm
going to go.
Row one
minus Row 2
and then whatever the evaluates to I'm going to plug that into Row 1.
So we will get something that looks like this.
Okay, 100 minus 100. That's just zero.
100 minus 100 that will stay 100
and then 3,000 minus 1,000 gives
us 2000.
Look at that.
now we have
a upper triangle
The last thing I need to do is get these to be once.
And what I will do is I will multiply this by one
over 100.
So cancel them out so to denote
that.
step
I'm going to say.
that I will multiply
I will multiply.
all the numbers on Row 1 with 1 over
and then
I'm going to
replace Row 1
what the result of this?
calculation right arrow
so that will do what it will give me.
100 over 100
100 over 100. That's just one.
Zero over 100. That's just zero and then 1000 over
100 is just 10.
And then I'm going to do the same thing for row number two, so I'm
going to copy this bit.
Okay.
I'm gonna do the same
thing for row number two.
Okay.
multiply these values
with one over 100
and then this is what's going to happen.
So zero over 100 this is going to be zero.
That's going to be one.
And then 2,000 over 100 is going to be 20.
And of course, I hope you can see the solution. It's with
we've managed to do it if I
put put back.
the
You know.
times 10 to the power 4
Well, we'll get this Matrix.
This one sorry but 10 to the power 4.
times 10 to the power 4
times 10
To the power of 4.
This is exactly what we had seen in our last
session.
Right. So what is this if we plug in these
values back into the
Inequalities we had this would give us or after
we turn the ecology the equations we would get One X.
plus 0y equals 10
times
10 to the power 4 which is 10 million.
And then for the one below.
the one below this would become zero X
1 y
times 10 to the power 4
and of course if we get rid of these zeros, I'm
only putting the leading one just so you can see how I
imply like what I'm plugging these numbers.
but in algebra, of course, we don't actually put
one
we don't put the coefficient one.
That because that's implied. It's there. So the
one goes away.
0 y That's Just well, that's nothing that goes
away.
Here down here zero X so the
X goes away.
And then one why we don't actually need to put the Y we
don't need to put the one and there we go. That's exactly what we have. This
is the this was the the point on the feasible region.
so
we looked at we have now seen two ways of solving our
system inequalities one was.
with the
Classical algebra and now we've used Gauss elimination from
linear algebra.
No.
In my opinion, this is still time-consuming.
right, I do you think would you
say this is simpler than
The algebraic manipulation we saw
in our last session or easier.
So gaussian elimination versus
Classical object which one do you think is easier?
Those are the same.
I suppose.
I would say however if you're doing multiple inequalities,
your gaussian will
will be more will be a lot
faster.
Which it says more organized I agree because you don't have to move things to
the left to the right.
But yeah.
I think with some practice you might find.
Galaxy elimination furthermore. Here's another
thing.
You probably won't do this by hand in real life. Like
if you have an actual LP problem and you have to solve
system of equations, you're not gonna do this by hand that will be ridiculous. Right?
We have calculators now.
They calculate which I'm referring are casts.
CIS computer algebra system
You know like TX, Texas Instruments
makes them you would plug in your you
would type in your equation.
Then say software Y and you will get the roots.
Or you could but if you have like many constraints our
caste system is going it's not going to be useful. So
you want to use something like Matlab or numpy to
solve many system of equations. So in
in the in the real world calculation or
at least earlier the conversation which we'll get to is
going to be far.
up for a more efficient approach and classical
logic
and exactly. Yes, you do need to plan a plan of attack,
but you have to sit down and think through it whereas with
Technologies like Matlab and
libraries like numpy you just
Write a line of code.
And you have the solution.
Okay.
But I hope you you now see what we have done.
You know understand Galaxy elimination.
So we swapped row two with Row 1 we subtracted
row two from Row 1 and then we the difference
we plugged into Row 1 and you get the idea.
Okay.
Let me show you the code to do the
same thing in numpy.
And then what's with familiar with once we get get the syntax
of numpy? I'll switch over to
talk about types of matrices.
And then once but then we'll we're ready to talk about Led composition.
So I'm going to open.
new notebook
Matrix operations
ipy
and B
Oh, not again.
I'm telling you this was literally working our while ago.
Why does it happen? Okay, never mind.
Let me just make sure it's yeah, it's 3.9. Okay.
So now what I need to do is go back up here
and do.
Gaussian elimination, but with no pie. So what I'm gonna first do
is import numpy.
import
numpy
as NP
and then I'm going to use S to represent my
system
Cuba great question what vs code plan are using
it's called Jupiter.
So if you want to do jupyter notebook whether I recommend this
versus installing Jupiter notebook separately if you
click on the extension the
extension icon these four boxes
Search for Jupiter.
do
better
and all you need to do is Click.
Install restart vs code and you've
got to go.
Now the reason I have to wait a while for Notebook to
open up is because I have different python versions.
I shouldn't uninstall them. But otherwise for you
should be straightforward.
I've attached instructions on the dashboard.
Or vs code so go to the instructions and you
can have the same setup.
Okay, so I'm gonna have
S stand for my system of
in a qualities here. So we have
two rows
with
and 3,000 again. I'm gonna leave out the 10
to the power 4 part.
And this is 200.
Okay, so and of course, I'm going to turn this into a numpy array
because I want to perform.
Matrix operations using numpy
Okay.
So let's begin.
Now the first thing I did was swap Row 2
and Row 1. I'm just going to do that up here. I'm just going to
swap them around like so
okay.
now
if I want to
subtract row
2 from Row 1
I would do it this way. So we have row.
And of course we have to remember that we count from zero
in in programming. So if I
want to say the first row, I would have to put in 0
and if I want to say row two two minus one,
that's one.
Okay, so I want to subtract these two.
if I say
Now there is something I need. I need you to also know.
Pie has a methods for Matrix operations.
So if I say NP
I'm going to go.
difference
the difference of
the first
well, what did we do here? We subtracted the second row.
From the first row. So that's S1.
S zero
I knew I'm gonna I knew I should have checked something.
Let me let me double check something by the way, because I only
check this for multiplication. Not for difference. Let
me just confirm.
What does this give me first of all?
Okay, so for addition and subtract, it's for additions difference.
I
I can use python.
You see because if you don't turn into a numpy object.
The default behavior from python is this
let's say you have to make you have two lists five
five or four four and five five.
If you do addition that doesn't apply make sure
it's just going to append.
These two lists together.
Up here. However, I am or if up here.
However, I am not.
These are not python lists. These are.
Array objects. Okay. I think
there is a there is a method for taking difference of
these two.
and
in fact, I think I should use the method.
I'll come back this difference method, okay?
I'll come back to the difference method. But yeah, if
you want to subtract the second row.
From the first row so subtract the second of the first row.
We type in the first row minus second row and
then it will subtract the second row from the
first row. And then if I want to replace the first row, I'm
going to go that's
sub z s of zero.
Equals well that difference.
And to see the result I'm going to Simply print.
Yes, so let me run this again.
by print s
you can see we have done just that.
100 zero 1000 100
okay, and I can continue this way. So right
now I need to subtract Row 1
from Row 2 and then plug it into.
row to okay, so that's I mean this was
this was supposed to be
our underscore to
our underscore
to
just make careful here.
Okay.
So this I'm just gonna copy this bit.
So I'm going to subtract Row 1 from Row 2.
Does NP array override minus operation?
Well, yes, because now you're not
subtracting you're not performing now addition, of
course in Python it has
three
applications you can use it to add to
Numeric data types, so intent float, you can use
it to concatenate two strings together you can use it to
merge to list together.
So
I I want to see override because
these are objects so you can also append you
can also merge to objects together.
How do you mean it works?
Oh you mighty sequel.
Minus equal. Oh, okay. I didn't see the equal part. You
mean decrement?
To take the difference you did you use this to subtract.
a row from another row
If that's what you mean, then yeah that would work because because
if we say that if
we do something like a equals.
Or a minus equals for example
a minus B.
or my a minus equals B this
Is the same thing as saying?
a equals a minus B
So minus equals says whatever a yes
subtract B from it, so these two are equivalent.
Okay, but I'm
just trying to make this look as I'm trying to make the python code look
as much.
To you know to make it as close to what we
see in there and in the market and the math
so here I want to subtract.
the second row from the first row
and then replace the second rule.
And there we have it.
And then you get the idea right then we would multiply the
first row by whatever 100 and until
we get to this point.
Until we get X and Y.
Okay.
So I won't finish this this part you
can you can do this on your but I hope you get the idea now.
So what I'm going to do from this point I always is
show you
what?
inverse Matrix identity matrices do
to any any Square Matrix
and then we can see it's output.
every stop of the way
So now let me open a new
notebook.
And I'm going to call this.
LED composition you
Take compo.
station
Pi.
first some background into
linearly composition
Let me come back to the markdown file.
Suppose we have a matrix.
and we'll call this Matrix a
we can Factor this Matrix.
into two matrices lnu
now what is L? And what is U?
let me make sure to make the letters bold because
you know in linear algebra matrices are
both capitalized and written both.
characters
here
a
is the original Matrix?
U is the
upper triangle Matrix
Which is also the solution.
When you eliminate the rows.
So up here. Let me scroll up to give you some if I
scroll up here. This is the solution right for our system was a system of
inequalities.
now before we actually
made these leading ones.
we were able to get it to
Upper triangular form. This is upper angular form, right?
We have this diagonal if you exclude this augmented part.
so here
that's the upper triangle part.
Everything across everything on the principal diagonal
is a non-zero.
Now, this is small Matrix, but you remember what we talked
about right upper triangle is this?
upper triangle
if you get your Matrix into upper triangular form.
You have done your elimination.
So this is what they use stands for.
Okay.
so you
Is the upper triangular?
triangle Matrix
then
Ellie the L part the L part is which stands
for lower triangle.
is the product of all of
the elimination matrices so there is
a component that is not part of
this.
formula the elimination Matrix
Is the product?
of
elimination matrices
if there are multiple matrices we would say matrices if there's one
and then we would say one eliminate elimination Matrix.
so
What is an elimination Matrix? So now we have to talk about types of
matrices? Let's first talk about the identity Matrix.
Then let's let me show you how to get to an end to
get to L triangle.
To a lower triangle Matrix and then you will understand what we mean by
elimination matrices.
so
let's begin with an example.
Let's say
we have this Square Matrix.
Let me borrow the related code.
from here
Let's say we have the square Matrix and we will denote this
with e a.
What do we have in this Matrix? We have the numbers 1 2 minus 3.
minus 3
then we have three.
or and 13
thank you for
and then we have two one and five
two one.
time
we want to factorize this Matrix. We want to
extract from this Matrix.
the L Matrix and the U Matrix
To get to the U Matrix we must first
do the L Matrix.
To get to the L Matrix. We need a sequence of elimination matrices.
Here's the idea.
In the previous example where we use gaussian
elimination.
Yes, we did those raw operations, but we did not keep track.
of which
numbers we used
or what order we used.
Well, I guess you could say we keptract because
here I have.
You know R minus R2 replaced R2,
but that's not what I mean. When I say keeping track
of the operations. I mean having a matrix.
Or a collection of matrices that says you
did this to row one and then you do this to row two
and then you do this to row three and these are written in matrices.
Now what I actually mean let me show you.
Let me drag this let me implement this
Matrix in numpy. So I'm going to keep this
here and I'm gonna open LED composition that IP Y and
B.
Okay, once again, I will import.
numpy as MP
and then I'm going to recreate this Matrix.
so we have in
P dot array, okay
NP dot array
And this has three rows.
one two
two negative 3
and then we have negative 3.
negative 4
and 13
and then finally we have two.
one
Okay.
The first thing we are going to do is
what we want to do is again, we want to get to Upper triangular form,
right so we want
This to be zero.
and then these two to be 0
okay this to be zero is to be 0
this to be 0 and everything across the diagonal should be
a non-zero value.
How would we get rid of?
Negative 3 that's the first thing we need to make 0.
Well, let's see one way to get rid of three.
Is to First multiply this row by 3.
So this would come 3.
This would become 6 that would become negative 9 but we
don't care about these two what's important to us? Is that if we
multiply this row by three then we
could add these two together.
Three plus negative 3 would cancel out row two.
And as far as we're concerned that's considered elimination.
Now we could also now
I could I can use the same code I did another file.
As zero plus S2, but that's
gaussian elimination. We don't want to do gaussian lamination and
in the elimination Matrix
Okay, let me show you what I mean.
Now this I will denote as a
And then I'm going to create a matrix called I called NP
dot array. This is gonna be the identity Matrix that
I've been talking about.
What's in the identity Matrix?
You have a square Matrix.
That is the same size as the
Matrix to what you want to
Multiply this identity Matrix and we have these values.
This becomes 0 this becomes one.
This becomes zero. This becomes 1 basically, I an identity
Matrix.
Is a matrix with zeros
everywhere except across the diagonal the
main diagonal?
Why is it called a why is it called identity Matrix?
Let me show you.
I will show you the result of this evaluation.
And then I'll show you a picture.
I'm going to go NP.
dot matte more
this is short for matrix multiplication.
So I'm going to apply the identity Matrix to
the original Matrix.
When I multiply this.
You can see we get the same Matrix again.
I mean, it's the same thing.
one two negative 3
1 to negative 3 negative 3 negative 4 13 negative.
How was this possible?
Well, let me show you. Well, this is the result of matrix multiplication. So
I'm going to pull up a picture of Matrix.
multiplication
and the way it works is
This is a this is a good example the way you will multiply
two matrices.
easy with multiply
well
the first number
in the first row times the first number
in the First Column of the second row.
then the
first number second number of
the first row times the second number
In the First Column of the second Matrix see that's
a mouthful if you look at the picture you should get the idea.
And then the product and then the sum I should say the sum.
of these two products or two times three zero times
four that would become the first value in the
resulting Matrix
so
I don't want to have to do this by hand because we'll run out of time.
But I want you to trust me when I say, okay. Let me see if I can do identity
Matrix identity.
identity
the by arranging the numbers and
identity Matrix
Like what we just saw we will get back the same resulting Matrix.
hopefully
yeah, look at this one.
so one times
this is not clear. Let's try not one.
You can take a second or two to look at this. So one times a
And then 0 times C. And then
zero times e holy see these zeros
right these zeros.
are going to cancel out the other terms and
all you left is one times a
and what times a is just a
Okay.
So I'm going to take this picture, but
for now look at this so that you're convinced that.
The identity Matrix will give you the make the
original Matrix. I'll put a picture of it in the tutorial.
but
let's just accept that this is the I did The Matrix will give you the
same Matrix.
I'm going to put this over here.
identity Matrix
I'll clean up the notes here later.
identity
Matrix
that's one. There's another one called the inverse Matrix.
Let me show you a picture of that.
with the
inverse Matrix
No, this is not what I wanted to show you.
No, no. Sorry. I I misspoke. This is not what I want to show you right now.
This is what I want to show you.
so
let's close this and focus here.
Okay.
What we're gonna do now is we're going to play around with this identity
Matrix.
and
we want to use it. We want to use this identity Matrix.
Not to get the same Matrix back.
but to get a third Matrix where
two rows have either been swapped around
or they've been manipulated somehow.
So let's take let's do this. Let's do the
first one. Let's do the first elimination Matrix.
Slowly so we understand what's going on in here.
We have one two.
Negative 3 and then we have negative 3 negative 4.
Okay, what we want to do is get this Matrix.
gradually into upper triangular form
so to
To do that we need this negative 3 to become zero.
Then we want to get this 2 to 0 and I'll
give this one to be equal to 0.
So these numbers?
You must get to be equal to 0.
using this identity Matrix or
an adaptation of the identity Matrix
Let me show you something. I'm going to copy this
code.
And instead of having one one. I'm
going to go.
One one in the opposite direction. So I'm flipping the
axis.
Let's see. What happens when I do that.
I'm going to call this.
Let me
give this another name. I'm going to call this I underscore.
Okay.
What happens when I do that?
Can you can you can you see what has
happened?
the third row
Which is 215.
Is now at the top.
And the first row which is one two negative three.
Is now at the bottom.
By point is the way we would.
Where we put a 1.
is going to allow us to
What performable operations then you see if I can give you a
very simple example?
A very simple I will come back this original one.
So I'm just going to create a very small Matrix. Let me call this.
M.
Just a 2 by 2.
and
let's make this.
to
and zero
and we'll make this one and one.
Okay, I want to
solve this Matrix
using
a modified version of the identity Matrix
Okay.
So we have one zero.
zero one ones across the diagonal obviously
and like before if I were to multiply these matrices.
I would get back the same Matrix.
Okay, 2 0 1 1 2 0 1
1 now if I want to solve this Matrix, I would
have to subtract two.
from one
so
what I'm gonna do now is I'm gonna go I'm gonna call this
e if we're elimination,
and
I'm going to set this to one.
If I run this, let's see what happens.
Actually, I want this to be negative one.
No.
I want this to be.
Okay, I need to make sure I get the order correct.
No, no, no one second thoughts. Let me
cheat.
What did I put here?
Yeah, so the elimination yeah the elimination Matrix comes
first.
And let me run this again.
I want this to be.
negative one
I'll tell you in a second.
if I want
Because the order of the arguments are important the sign is
important. So the order of the arguments so here
I need to go from
Okay.
Let's do it 200 100.
by the first row
Just give me a second multiply.
Yeah.
What? Yeah, so I want to multiply the first
row.
with the second row together 0
And then I have the original Matrix.
and then e
yeah.
Yeah, I have to be careful with the order of these matrices.
Okay.
so
let me bring that back.
So this the original Matrix right again, that's the identity Matrix.
one on the principal diagonals
if I set this to
negative 1
here's one way to read it.
Let me actually plug in more numbers in here just to expand just to
make this bigger. So you have some.
A better idea. I will make these zero down here.
Okay.
And I need the Matrix to be.
the same size
Again, if I set this to zero, you have an identity Matrix.
if I set this to negative 1
Basically, here's one way to interpret it.
We're saying multiply.
the second row
or not multiply add to the
second row.
the difference of the first row
add to the second row.
So whatever two is.
So imagine this is R1.
This would be R2. This would be R3.
This is one way to this is how you you read the
rows of an elimination Matrix.
Add two row two.
negative one of R1
so basically multiply these by negative 1
and add it to the second Matrix the second row.
so when you mother when you add two
to
negative 2 to 1. So that's
two plus one
I just want to make this part clear. So let me just add this comment
here.
So, this is R1 R2.
all of these are R1
R2
or 2 and everything here's R3. So basically
here's what I'm trying to say.
Okay.
Because elimination Matrix is a type of encoding
Matrix.
if you keep
What's across the diagonal to one so if I keep this one I'm
saying.
Keep Row 1 what it is.
If I make this one and the other zero.
I'm sick. Do not change row two keep R2
what it is.
And if I set these to zero.
And I make this one that I'm saying keep R3
what it is.
if however I
make this one I'm saying keep R3
what it is.
But add R1 to it.
So it's like I'm activating rule one.
Row 1 will be added to
Row 3
so for example
Let me make this 0 again.
Okay. Once again, we will get the same Matrix.
If I set this to one.
well
Because these are because the these are these are
zeros, right? The third one is a zero.
Let me just let me just go back to the a matrix.
But I'm trying to get across this idea
that we can play around with this identity
Matrix to eliminate.
And get to the upper triangle.
So let's return to the above example.
And do this again? Okay. I'm going to go back to
the identity Matrix.
Set these.
to zero
Okay.
I'll do one example.
But I think by the second when I get to the second
the third elimination matrices, you should get the idea. Okay.
so
If I run this now.
I
Need to make this one if I run this now, I'm going to
get the I say Matrix.
So want to negative three one two negative 3.
Negative 3. Okay. I hope you can see they're all the same. Okay. Now
I'm going to make this my first elimination Matrix.
To get to my first elimination Matrix. I need to get rid of minus three
and it is to become a zero.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to create my first elimination Matrix.
This will be a modification of the identity
Matrix.
So to get rid of this.
Negative 3 I need to multiply Row three
a row once excuse me, multiply Row
1 by 3.
So this will become three. This will become six. This will become negative
9 and then add this row.
to the second row
because three plus negative 3 they cancel each other and we
get to zero.
So I'm going to go.
negative 3
Okay.
And then I'm going to multiply them together.
So I'm going to multiply my first elimination Matrix.
times a
Okay.
It's supposed to be negative 3 or 3.
It's supposed to be 3.
So you see here?
Our first row is the same.
Our third row is the same but now we have
discarded or I should say we have yeah, we
have discarded the
The leading negative 3 in the second row.
That's my first elimination Matrix.
and my so I will now reassign a
to this evaluation
Okay, so my a has been updated.
Like we run this again.
So now I need to create a second elimination Matrix
to get rid of two.
and then one
so let's do that. I'm going to copy this.
Make it a identity Matrix again.
And let's see what numbers I need to modify in
this identity Matrix to get rid
of the two.
Okay.
To get rid of two.
I would have to multiply Row 1 by 2.
And then subtract it from the third row.
So negative 2 plus 2 and I will get a leading
zero.
So what I'm going to do next is
multiply
Row one
by two
and then add that to
the second row
Let's see what that does.
This is going to be E2. It has that's the second
elimination Matrix.
And I actually want this to be negative 2.
run that
I keep getting these signs wrong to be
careful.
Now after turn this from the top don't you need to
move the negative 2 down the last row in the
in the E Matrix? Oh, yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes.
Yes. You're correct. Oh, correct.
so I need to
multiply
The first row by two and then add it so yeah multiply the
first row by two.
negative 2 rather
and then add it to the third row.
Yeah, I have to be careful.
So this is what I want.
Multiply the first row by a negative 2 add it
to the third row.
one more time
There we go.
Now don't worry about the second row because we already have the elimination Matrix
up here.
For the second row. We have the element elimination Matrix.
This is the elimination Matrix for the third row. So as
you can see we've gotten it to become.
A zero, but now there is this negative 3 that also
needs to be a zero.
So I'm going to create a third
elimination Matrix.
I'm going to take this again.
Gonna set this back to zero and let me see what number I
must use.
to get rid of negative 3
What do you think?
How do we get rid of that?
Negative 3 in the in the middle
of the third row.
So what I could do.
at 6 over 2
at 6 over 2. So yes, so at 3 at positive
3 to that but I need to
use one of these so either have to divide this
by two.
or I can multiply this by 1.5 2
times 1.5 gives us 3
so what I can do is multiply.
the first row
by negative
one and a half so three over five is one and half.
This is negative 1/2.
And then add that to the third rule so multiply the
first rule by a negative 1.5.
And then add that to the third
row.
Okay, hopefully I got this right let me run this and again this needs
to be three.
This needs to be three.
run this
no, I still made a mistake. Let me run this again from the top.
I have to be very careful with when I do this.
Run it from the top.
and
okay one more time.
One more time. Let's go back.
I will definitely edit this part out this going back
and forth part.
Okay, let's do this one more time. So again
I can't think I pressed 9 instead of
0.
one more time
This is our Matrix. We have negative 3 and we
want to multiply the first row.
By 1.5.
To get rid of the third row.
2 over 2 goes into one.
Okay. Yes. You're correct.
Okay, let me check two things. Yeah, this should go here.
Well, I'm reassigning something incorrectly.
I reassigned something is off here.
Let me just copy this Matrix making my life easier. So
this is the resulting Matrix going to copy this.
And every place it.
Okay.
So I don't have to run this from scratch every
time.
Okay, we want to get rid of the three.
in here
Okay.
then
that's just going to be 0 0.
one
zero
zero and then three over two.
Okay one more time.
I think I was wrong about that. I think you had the minus
3 over 2 on the right column, but I think you have
to put a one in the second column Row three.
Yes here is that we talked about? Okay. Let me just run this see
the thing is there's so much going on.
It's easy to lose track.
and here
no, this is definitely I'm getting close to solution.
But I just misplaced something. Let me just make sure what I
misplaced.
two three zero two
because I even have my reference code here.
one two three
Yeah, I misplaced. I saw I misplaced one
of these minus pluses have been swapped around.
Okay.
This is supposed to be.
This is supposed to be one. How did it get to 11?
It's because something up here went wrong.
Let me run this one more time.
So this is the original Matrix the identity Matrix.
Multiply a by the identity Matrix. We'll get the
original Matrix this and that are equivalent.
Then I came down here.
I took the original Matrix.
These two are the same this one.
then multiplied three
to the first row
So this would become three three plus minus 3,
this would become zero.
And that's how we get the zero down here.
So the three has been eliminated.
Then let me just copy this Matrix.
So this is the new a
this is the new way.
Okay, the zero has been eliminated, but now I
need to get two to be eliminated.
so to get rid of this two, I'm going
to multiply the first row by
negative 2 so negative 2 plus 2
And this zero.
And the zero disappear so negative 2 plus 2 and
then 0 will disappear.
So I'm going to run this.
Okay.
And there we have it.
The zero has disappeared.
Now we're left with this negative 3, so I'm going to copy this.
and then I'm going to
hardcoded
Okay.
So this is where we are now.
The zero has been eliminated here. The zero has been eliminated here.
But now we need to get rid of this negative 3.
So what I can do, well, I have two twos here.
I can use either row two or Row 1.
so
I could use either one of these I could multiply the second
row by 1.5.
And then add it to the third row.
so I can
be careful with my signs here.
I can multiply the second row.
By 1.5. So this becomes three and then
at 3.
To negative 3 to get this to disappear.
Okay, let me try that now.
And there we have it.
So we are now an upper triangle.
One two negative three and zeros here.
Okay, so
obviously that was a lot of I had to be very careful
with how I the problem was I was reassigning it. I have
to be careful with that.
And so every time we make a mistake have to go back running from the top. But right
now we have this upper triangular form, right? This is what I
meant to say.
So the L triangle that I'm referring to is going
to be the final.
Elimination Matrix. So what do I mean?
Let me take those. Let me take the the three
elimination Matrix matrices that I created. So I'm going
to open a sidebar here.
I'm going to add E1 E2
and E3 down here. So this is E3.
And then this is E2.
And this is E1.
Okay.
The L. Matrix is going to be.
all three of these matrices put together
so we have
1 0 0
then we have three one zero.
By the way, I meant to make this a negative 3.
But let me just plug in 3 for a second three zero.
and then
I have a negative 2 here.
And 3 over 2 here, so I'm going to put here negative 2.
3 over 2
and then zero, so this is what
I mean by
the L Matrix being the product.
of
a sequence of elimination matrices
And this is what I meant to say. This is what I meant when I said the
In LED composition we keep track of
our operations. So it's one thing to write down the steps.
It's another thing to put them into matrices like
so
Okay.
So let me push these away.
Get everything to be nicely aligned.
Question the chat someone's on the diagonal needed.
Yes. Yes this one we need correct?
Be very careful.
Okay. Now I want to show you what happens when I multiply L
by U now when I look at my notes, I
noticed that I misplaced.
the signs
so
For example here. I have to put a negative 3.
And here I meant to make this two.
And make this negative.
So this would be two this would be negative.
And this would be negative 3 because my
original Matrix.
Let me write it down. You know, it's just safer to write things down.
From scratch when you make mistakes like this, so that's a
small Matrix.
And let me pay careful attention. So this is
one
two and negative 3 and the
first row second row is negative 3
negative 4
negative 5
all right.
So this is the a this is the original Matrix. This is
the L Matrix now the upper Matrix. The U Matrix
is the
Matrix after we
eliminated everything below the lower triangle. So that
was this one.
I'm not going to scroll up because I have it right here.
array
so this would be
the solution Matrix
it's the same thing we saw above but
Earlier, I got the side. I got the negatives wrong. So I'm just going to type it here
correctly. So after we solve The Matrix a
we get one.
two negative 3
and then we have 0
to
and then 0
and this would be seven.
okay, the idea is this If I multiply
these two matrices together I should get back.
the original Matrix
So, let's see that I'm gonna add another cell here. I'm going
to go NP dot mat multiply matrices.
And I have to be careful with the order the order matters.
I'm going to go yes L times
U.
So if I make if I multiply these two these are the fact that
this is the factorization of the Matrix C. I should
get back the same Matrix.
So, let's see.
I need to run this cell first.
And I'm gonna run this.
Now these are floats, but if I scroll up a little
bit.
I think I got the signs wrong
again.
Because the first dose, correct.
The second row where did I misplace the
sign? One, two, three three four thirteen.
two one negative 5
this is one.
zero zero negative 3 1 0
there
3 1 0
3 1 okay one more time.
Yeah, now we have the same Matrix.
Okay, so one two negative three one two
negative 3.
and I can even convert this to an
Integer by using the as type method so I'm going to go ask type
make this an image integer.
There we go. So now we have the same Matrix as
we had about.
You know one to negative 3 1 to negative 3 3 4 yeah.
Okay, so I obviously I made a
few mistakes along the way.
But my point was this to summarize.
What we can do is we can take a square Matrix.
And factorize it
into two matrices.
The lower Matrix which is the combination
of the elimination matrices. We
just saw.
And then once you eliminate eliminate eliminate you get to
the upper triangle Matrix.
So we need elimination of matrices to get
to the L Matrix.
And once we get to the other Matrix viewer also acquired the
U Matrix.
This will become a factor.
In our next session, I'm going to review this will
also do an exercise on this.
and
I'm going to show you how to solve an actual system of equations.
using LED composition
So if you can see here our lower
triangular Matrix.
Or I should say our upper triangular. Matrix is
does not have leading ones. So we want to see how we can
go from lud composition to reduce row shillon form.
And that perhaps add this to our specific equations.
Any question or comments before I in
the session because I have one more comment about the assignment from
module 1 any questions comments.
Now, of course, I'm going to go back and edit this video check out the parts
where I was scrolling up and down.
So when you watch this back, it's not annoying. Yes. So just just be
clear. Your L. Matrix is the complete elimination
lower elimination make tricks.
Yes, if you want we can see something. Let me see you
so I'm just gonna hopefully Google will show us a picture.
of that expression so Leu decomposition
the composition
elimination
matrices
I think I had a PDF open here somewhere.
This is one but it's not complete.
You know, sometimes you have to do a bit of Google to find what
you're looking for. But yeah, that's that's the that's the idea.
That's the idea.
Any other questions?
Elimination matrices, please.
Marks now, let me tell you about the assignment. I was supposed to post it
post it yesterday.
But I'm actually onboarding other
lecturers.
All of whom will have phds all of them who have
experience teaching in Academia. So what I'm trying to do is, you know,
raise the bar and bring more advanced
mathematics.
But I'm going to post it. I'm
gonna try to post it today. And of
course I will extend the I want I will
adjust the deadline to accommodate for
You know the delay but assignment will
be very similar to the lp problem. We did and of course you can use.
the techniques we saw today guys elimination LED
composition to
solve that
LP problem
I think I found one here.
Yeah, something like this, but I'm not
sure about this website.
You know what? I always say about Google. I'll write it
down a lot. I'll add notes here. But this is the yeah. This is the idea the Lord
the L. Matrix is the product of
elimination matrices, okay.
Okay, everybody.
So that's it for today's session.
I need to come up with a way to write the code and not
Like go up and down so many times. So I what I'm
gonna try to do is write the code in advance just paste it to avoid
any back and forth. But sometimes I have to sometimes I have to
answer questions after making modification. Anyway, just keep your
eye out please on the
Dashboard because the assignment will appear here. There will be two links link
to the assignment link this
submission for and please don't forget what I said about if
you haven't joined slack yet you do so.
Okay, because I'm going to add comments in here
And that's it. So I'll see you
all on.
Wednesday same time.
Take care for now.
And enjoy the recipe. Bye.
Thanks, Danny.